let's talk about chris cuomo we got this
story from the new york times cnn
suspends chris cuomo after new details
on help he gave his brother the cable
news network's top-rated anchor was an
enthusiastic advisor to andrew cuomo in
the last 18 months of his governorship
but i love how they don't use the
headline chris cuomo suspended
indefinitely after stalking the victims
of his creepy cuomo brother instead
they're like well he was helping his
brother it's almost like they're trying
to sound like make it sound like a good
thing to get people to be like how could
they do that to chris cuomo but this is
an example of
media collusion democrat friendly media
chris cuomo on cnn cnn of course is not
a news institution at this point they're
content creators it's about what they
are and they not only give favorable
coverage to their democrat buddies they
not or chris cuomo not only helped cover
up or at least
not report on to be to be as fair as i
can the elderly who were being killed in
these nursing homes but he actively
assisted his brother it's a conflict of
interest for the network it's a conflict
of interest for him personally but the
craziest thing about it was that he was
actually trying to dig up dirt on those
who were accusing his brother
i think the crap i'm surprised to hear
it that cnn's actually suspending them
nobody believed was going to happen i
don't know what you guys think they got
fredo now please do uh cooper and wolf
blitzer please and the brain the brain
eating guy and the brain he's gone
already but there's also a potato head
in there and you know other vanderbilts
there's a lot of different people in
there but regardless of that it's
interesting to see him suspended because
it's it's also going to be
interesting to see if he got paid
vacation for this but with the way cnn
has been behaving i wouldn't be
surprised if they pull off another lube
and tubin kind of incident and he comes
back in six months and then gives kind
of a half-assed apology and then kind of
continues on with his trauma-based mind
control that he kind of spews to the
general public
so um i wouldn't be surprised if that
happens a lot of people are saying why
wasn't he fired i do think he's going to
come back but that's just my own
personal opinion later down
when everything kind of dies down yeah
i think for me i i wish i could join in
the the parade of celebration that and i
don't like chris cuomo either and i'm
happy that i mean i i think he deserves
to get fired it couldn't have happened
to a more deserving guy but at the same
time you just know that they're going to
replace him with someone who's 50 times
worse it's the same thing that happened
in new york and everybody on the right
was celebrating because andrew cuomo got
the ax and i was
i'm usually taking the cynical view of
things so and in that case i'm thinking
well
there's a reason why the left has
decided to throw this guy under the bus
because they never throw their own guys
under the bus and they're only going to
do it if they know they have somebody
waiting in the wings who's going to be
even more their servant on the far left
and so then kathy hockeau gets in there
and um that's how you say your name
hockey that's how i said i have no idea
if that's actually right hokule i don't
know but she gets in there and she's far
more far left than than cuomo was and so
you know it's going to be the same thing
i think they're going to replace them
with someone
like their own version of joy read or
something i mean cnn take a look at you
know andrew and chris cuomo
they're white men
so certainly i know it's you know a
little silly to bring up but i'm willing
to bet that there are uh culty locusts
who are just like
what can we do to remove these guys
and so they'll exploit any any crisis
now truth be told
andrew cuomo there's pictures of him
grabbing people and then my favorite
thing about his whole scandal was he was
like let me show you all the montage of
me grabbing more people to prove that i
do it to everybody and i'm like oh so he
admits it right but chris as a member
as a staff member at cnn we all we all
assumed even yesterday talking about
this that he was gonna be protected the
fact that they're suspending him
indefinitely
it could mean that they're gonna they
could decide to bring him back and say
pending further review or whatever but
yeah they're gonna have to have someone
fill that slot immediately
then how much you want to bet it's going
to be someone who's particularly woke
yeah i bet there's probably some inner
politics that we don't even know about
that kind of unfolded here because to
see both como brothers taken down by the
establishment
kind of shows that there's something
else happening here that we don't know
about i mean it was the new york
attorney general that released the
private messages between him and his
brother so so obviously something bigger
here is at play i wouldn't be surprised
if it's a bigger power move and if there
was a request for the comos to do
something and then they kind of turned
it down i think there's a possibility
for that but again we're kind of
speculating here but why did she release
the text do we know
she's for one thing she's running for
governor so she wants his job so that's
yeah that's one thing
uh but you also brought a good point
about i didn't even think about this but
uh but tuban yeah so
lubin tubin is officially his internet
yeah his name is tubin right come on
somehow he survives and the thing about
that the people talk about that and they
say well he he accidentally was on
camera
it was a big mishap no
he didn't know he's on camera but he
didn't accidentally fall and trip and
and you know pleasure himself that
that that party did on par he he knew
that he was on you know he tried to do
that during a meeting the only thing is
he didn't know that people were watching
him so
that's a a really serious infraction
when it comes to sexual harassment in
the workplace and somehow he survives
that at cnn and
women at cnn have to like go into the
break room and be around this guy you
know drinking a cup of coffee knowing
he's at a meeting with with other women
and he's lubing the tubing i mean
and imagine your conversations with
someone it's just sick on so many levels
like how more like perverted can you get
this cnn it is cnn it is pretty pretty a
cd place
yeah i'm like with everything that's
gone at cnn first we got the guy who ate
the brains remember that reza oslan
eight human brain oh yeah yeah he ate
razza aslan ate human brains then he
lost his mind and well maybe he was
always crazy yeah but he eats human
brain i just gotta say it a couple times
like people need to understand this
about the cnn host did a show where he
sat down with a bunch of you know
religious it was like a hindu extremist
group they gave him a small piece of
brain and he ate it yeah so you've got
things like that how did they get the
brain
i don't know i don't know i have no idea
i think it was from a deceased person if
i remember correctly the video is still
up on youtube and youtube still actively
promotes cnn even though they cause so
much irreversible harm to
female employees and other individuals i
was going to say that too so you not
only have that you have you know chris
cuomo and the conflicts of interest and
and you have um don lemon he's facing
charges yeah he also assaulted a guy and
well he's accused of assaulting a guy
yeah
what do you do he shoved his hands in
his pants and then shoved him in the
guy's face the details are of course
contested here but it's uh you know
adult assault family-friendly show of of
another man those are the accusations
accusations against them it's going to
go
uh
in a trial soon it's going to be
divulged i want all the details so it's
going to be and now and then we have
obviously cuomo's conflict of interest
trying to dig up dirt on the accusers
against his brother and now that we got
to get into this tubing thing because
you brought up a really good point and i
want to stress this imagine you are you
know
so here's what happens with tube and
he's in a virtual was like a zoom
meeting right with a bunch of people
and he decides he's going to crank it
out while watching all of his co-workers
right
and he didn't realize his camera was
still on so they suspended they bring
him back now you put up a really good
point in the break room but imagine this
imagine you got to call the guy and
you're you're like imagine a female
employee
and they're and they're told like oh can
you get on getting a call with tuban
nope no no no
uh-uh hold on i gotta i gotta write
something down like because well imagine
this imagine imagine what it would be
like if you're you know
i don't care if you're a man or woman
and you call this guy and he's on a
treadmill and like he's panting and
breathing heavy
yeah tell me
about the project
yeah i don't think he spends a lot of
time on a treadmill
tell me more how you hate trump oh god
a lot of people are laughing that i said
that the brain came from a deceased
person and people were saying yeah
obviously yeah
there's also a lot of let's go fredo
comments in the chat room
and i think one of the best comments
that i saw about this situation was from
danny polishchuck who said another
content creator bites the dust
with the news of fredo getting fired so
uh
have you seen uh do you watch like ryan
long's comedy
yeah yeah yeah he uh he did a bit with
uh danny polish chuck i'm saying that
wrong all right
danny's joke was
call call these journalists content
creators because and then ryan is like
you know that the people on the the
leftist journalists will freak out and
the right would be like or whatever like
not really care
so
i agree so i've been calling the people
at cnn content creators
they're not journalists well it's like
the msnbc they decided that rachel
maddow wasn't actually a journalist
they're like oh she's giving too much of
an opinion to be a journalist so it's
like yeah she's basically a content
creator what'd you call it i mean you
know i think it's fine to call them
pundits yeah you know what i mean but
content creator is is
meant to like
ryan nails it yeah you know it's gonna
drive them crazy and none of us would
care to be called like i don't know
whatever i like the old school kind of
prostitutes i think that has a nice ring
to it
personally myself but i think
universally if we just all started
calling them content creators it would
really bother them and get underneath
their skin so i think we should
normalize this and implement this rule
this kind of unspoken rule like hey if
we're going to refer to these people one
we shouldn't be calling them the
mainstream media they're the corporate
media too
they're not journalists they're content
creators yeah and um cnn's media content
creator brian stelter of course will
eventually run a segment being like the
new attack from the right referring to
hard-working journalists content
creators
and then he'd have yeah republican
sponsors and they'd have like a round
table of like you know the strategy here
is really to diminish the world the role
we do and holding power to account and
speaking truth to power and yeah
remember when they compare themselves to
like active military members cnn did
this they're like yeah we're the best of
like 2015 yeah brian williams did that
perfectly too it's a good it's a good
point too because i i actually wouldn't
care
the bias and all that kind of stuff it
wouldn't bother me if we if they were
just called something else the fact that
they claimed to be journalists is the
problem because the thing is we hear
everyone complain about oh bias in the
media the media's always been biased go
back and read like
headlines from newspapers during the
civil war era and it's just it's it's
extremely partisan the difference is
back then they didn't pretend otherwise
they embrace the fact that we have a
point of view so the problem with cnn is
that they if they would just admit that
look we come from a left-wing
perspective this is what we care about
this is our perspective then like fine
do your thing just don't pretend
otherwise
it's weird though i mean
i don't think the the current left-right
phrasing you know says this for a while
it makes literally no sense but i i've
kind of come to an understanding the rea
the reality is there are two realities
and so i think all of us in this room
exist in one political compass reality
and that is honest and true reality of
course we believe that that's why we're
all sitting here but what i mean is
you know we fact check things um we try
to make sure we get things right good
example the covington kids this big fake
news you know thing thrown on the media
or kyle rittenhouse we're the kind of
people whether we agree or disagree on
certain political policies or you know
certain uh you know economic policies
we all agree on what is real because
we've looked at and said oh okay trump
didn't really do anything wrong when he
was throwing the food into the koi pond
he was just doing what shinzo abe did
but then you have this other political
compass of people who live in the matrix
it's almost like a blue pill red pill
political compass
so it's funny when you see these people
will say like this show is right wing
what they're really saying is they exist
in a separate reality because i
certainly think i'm to the left of you
matt you know and like we can agree on
the truth but we probably disagree on
policy positions but we can sit here and
have conversation because we agree on
what is real
so
that's kind of the point you know to
talk about the leftists and to mention
cnn well
populist socialist types would be like
cnn is not left-wing they're a
right-wing it's like no no hold on in
your your bubble world yeah yeah cnn is
is is the right wing in the fake reality
they live in the corporate press is
authoritarian and right-wing so it's
almost like they have their own um scale
of right and left that's right that's
right yeah yeah so they're like um this
is cnn is right wing and then everything
else thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time